[Applause]
[Music]
he's a politician but he's not just any
politician his biography is what you
would expect from the protagonist of a
best-selling political fiction novel
however dear viewer this is a
flesh-and-blood politician with both the
good side into dark side we're talking
about Benjamin Netanyahu Israel's prime
minister and the most powerful
politician the country has had in the
last two decades this is a country that
works people work they invent things and
rent things that change life this is
past this is future yes I found in the
times that I've been in government that
the most rapid technology transfers
occurred when businesses operated with
each other Israel is often called the
startup nation I call it the innovation
nation the future belongs to those who
innovate those who don't innovate rather
in companies or in countries will fall
behind innovation is the only way to
consistently add value to your products
and services in an increasingly
competitive global economy
[Music]
but you may be wondering why are we
talking about Netanyahu today why is he
so important well folks what if I told
you that this man was the architect he
basically designs the Israel that we
know today yes you heard that right
we're talking about a politician who has
so much character that he actually
attacked the very president of the
United States in front of his own
Congress yes indeed this happened at
Barack Obama so don't tell me that this
guy isn't it tough before lifting those
restrictions the world should demand
that Iran do three things first stop its
aggression against its neighbors in the
Middle East second stop supporting
terrorism around the world and third
stop threatening to annihilate my
country Israel the one and only Jewish
state
[Applause]
[Music]
while the fact is that Benjamin
Netanyahu or Bibby as is known in Israel
has done practically everything in his
country during his time as a soldier and
remember here the military service is
mandatory in Israel he commanded a
special forces unit and he participated
in plenty of operations which have names
like you'd see in a Hollywood movie
names like Operation Inferno and
operation isotope where by the way
Netanyahu was shot while his unit
rescued a plane hijacked by the
terrorist group the Black September
organization look I'm 28 years old I've
had to defend my country in two wars and
in many battles as a soldier he also
participated in operations in Egypt
Syria and Jordan but that's not all
after finishing his military service
this Prime Minister went to the United
States to study and well now you might
be wondering well where did he study
well first it was MIT and then it was
Harvard and by the way here's some
curious trivia in 1973 when the Yom
Kippur War broke out between Israel and
its Arab neighbors Netanyahu who was
studying in Boston returned home to
rejoin the Special Forces until the war
ended but moving on from trivia let's
continue the fact is that after studying
in the United States and spending some
time working in consulting he got
involved in politics where a game he's
done everything he has been a member of
Parliament's and ambassador to the UN
Minister of Foreign Affairs Minister of
Finance and of course Prime Minister for
four terms in fact my friends he's about
to become the Israeli prime minister
with the longest time in office however
now his position of influence and power
is being questions so let's take a look
at what is happening or why this man is
an election winning machine
[Music]
cornered on February the 12th 2018 after
a year of investigations the Israeli
police recommended the Attorney General
bring charges against Benjamin Netanyahu
you see the police state there are clear
indications of corruption bribes and
influence peddling they accused the
Prime Minister of having received gifts
of hundreds of thousands of dollars of
having conspired to influence the media
and also of having protected millionaire
corruption in the multimillion-dollar
process of buying German submarines and
you know what this isn't the first time
that Israel's police have accused him
they also did it in 1997 and again in
1999 during Netanyahu's first term as
Prime Minister
back then the accusations ended with no
charges now again the Prime Minister has
made it very clear that he will not
yield nothing will have sway and nothing
will sway me not even the incessant
attacks against me Benjamin Netanyahu
the truth is that whether or not he's
finally accused Netanyahu is on the line
by the way it Israel nobody is immune to
justice in the last decades they have
condemned and imprisoned a former prime
minister ecwid Ahmet and an ex-president
Moshe Katsav so if Netanyahu is guilty
but he's gonna pain their forked if you
and in this video we're going to get to
know Israelis Prime Minister better
we're gonna take a look at his good and
his bad side and investigate what made
Netanyahu such an important character in
Israel's politics
[Music]
King bee bee the Saviour
Netanyahu might not be the most popular
guy on the planets but one thing is
absolutely certain
every time Bibby has come to power he's
done so under very very difficult
conditions during his first term when he
came to power in 1996 the country was
greatly unbalanced with an uncontrolled
public deficit and growing external debt
in 2003 when he was appointed Minister
of Finance under Ariel Sharon's
government the country was undergoing
its worst recession and the most current
time was in 2009 just when his country
was suffering the consequences of the
great international financial crisis
well in all these cases Netanyahu's
recipes they were and not only that with
his policies pitty has transformed this
country's identity thanks largely to his
governance Israel has gone from being a
place with chronic imbalances and crises
a country that in 1984 had to be rescued
by the United States to becoming a
prosperous country with well-organized
accounts and a worldwide power in
technology and innovation
[Music]
through all this we can understand how
despite all the controversy baby
continues to raise passions some against
him but many in favor of him but many of
you might not be thinking ok but what
were or rather what are Benjamin
Netanyahu's recipes well that's exactly
what we're going to look at next
traditionally Israel was a socialist
country with high taxes a lot of
regulation and a very large government
well the B's mission was to change this
model once and for all and enforce
another that would organize the accounts
and improve the country's
competitiveness I mean check this out
you think that mathematicians and
computer engineers or mechanical
engineers or doctors are first they're
very important but they're not first
they're second there was a country that
had the best mathematicians the best
physicists the best metallurgist in the
world for that country was very poor it
was called the Soviet Union what comes
first as markets this was the main thing
that I tried to bring to the Israeli
economy in my own way Benjamin Netanyahu
with this idea in mind in his first
mandate in 1996 his number-one priority
was to reduce the public deficit
privatized banks and large
government-owned companies and suppress
capital controls for example at that
time Israelis had a restriction on the
money that they could take out of the
country and use for buying foreign
currency yes we could say that the
Israel of the 90s resembled the curtain
as Argentina a lot of public spending
and capital controls but let's continue
[Music]
in 2003 when the country was undergoing
a terrible crisis as Minister of Finance
the Minister of Finance with a lot of
power by the way Netanyahu froze public
spending and launched a huge tax
reduction for example he reduced
corporate income tax as well as
individual income tax by half
[Music]
see when he arrived at the ministry the
maximum rate on income in terms of wages
was 64% when he left it was 44% a
20-point reduction in just two years and
when he came to power in 2009 he had a
similar recipe less public spending
fewer taxes and less bureaucracy in
addition in recent years he managed to
get Israel once and for all to exploit
its huge natural gas reserves Israel
bolsters Egypt ties with 15 billion
dollar gas deal it was precisely because
of this that many believe Israel's
miracle would not have been possible
without this Prime Minister but don't
think that he has only had good results
in the economic sector not at all in the
37 months that Netanyahu held office
Israeli citizens enjoyed one of the
safest and quietest periods with regards
to terrorism of the five Israeli leaders
examined Robyn Perez Netanyahu Barak
sharone Netanyahu's policies with
regards to the prevention and deterrence
of terrorism were the most effective in
deeds in addition to the economy Israeli
society recognizes Netanyahu as having
made Israel a safer country a safer
country and also very importantly a
country that is much more open to the
world so much so that this Prime
Minister has succeeded and listen up
here because I think this will amaze you
in getting relations between Israel and
the Arab countries to go well smoothly
and this is something that we certainly
need to dive more into and we'll do that
right now
[Music]
the external approach so you probably
know the popular saying my enemy's enemy
is my friend well it looks as if
something like this is happening in the
Middle East with Iran and with
fundamentalist groups like Isis I mean
check out the news that the New York
Times published on February the 3rd 2018
secret alliance Israel carries out
airstrikes in Egypt with Cairo's ok pay
close attention to this news bomb in the
last two years Israel has carried out
more than a hundred aerial attacks with
planes helicopters and drones against
fundamentalist groups in Egypt
particularly against the so-called
Islamic state of Sinai that is an Arab
government in this case the Egyptian
government has authorized Israel to
carry out attacks and operations within
its territory which is really quite
amazing that's not all Israel's
relations with Jordan in Egypt better
than ever but they're also growing
stronger with other Arab countries
including Saudi Arabia yeah you had that
right now they still aren't formal but
they are happening behind closed doors
there is an alignment of Israel in other
countries in the Middle East that would
have been unimaginable ten years ago
certainly in my lifetime I never saw
anything like it and I'm at the age of
the State of Israel more or less so it's
an extraordinary thing so how about
another example
well after 70 years of prohibition then
for the first time Saudi Arabia has
authorized an Israeli commercial flight
to cross its airspace since March Air
India flights between New Delhi and
tel-aviv will cross Saudi airspace this
might seem like a small step but it's
really not and you know what it's not
just the Arab countries the Prime
Minister has set his sights on the East
and has also established surprisingly
good relations with India Australia
Singapore and even China we are very
much very much excited by the Belgium
road initiative and what we seek is
merely an express lane in this belton
world that is called China Israel
relations and what's more Netanyahu led
the first visit of an Israeli prime
minister to Latin America in 2017 he
visited Mexico Colombia and Argentina
and in Africa well it's more of the same
[Music]
Israel is coming back to Africa and
Africa is coming back to Israel in fact
Netanyahu is the first Israeli leader to
visit this continent since the 1960s and
many African leaders are delighted with
Israel's money and Israel's technology
I saw diversity and richness
I saw passion and productivity I saw
young African entrepreneurs who were
building companies harnessing the power
of the digital age Africans are seizing
the future Israel wants to seize this
future with you in short as you can see
both in the economic field as well as in
security and foreign policy this Prime
Minister has many reasons to be proud
but of course not everything is a bed of
roses here
the dark side
we've denounced it before on visual
politic one of the greatest problems we
see with Benjamin Netanyahu in addition
to his corruption suspicions is his
position towards the West Bank
settlements yes Netanyahu supports these
settlements continual growth and as we
saw in recent years this government has
promoted a policy to expand and
consolidate them and it's more than
three years in power this government has
been irrational bordering on the
Messianic is now increasingly clear
where it is headed creeping annexation
of the West Bank aimed at precluding any
permanent separation from the
Palestinians
a who brought former Prime Minister of
Israel and besides these settlements
Netanyahu's power relations with some
magnets are also actually put it
questionable
for example his friends and gambling
mogul Sheldon Adelson invested 200
million dollars into Israel hayom
a free newspaper that greatly favors
Netanyahu the question that arises is
whether you have to return favor another
significant part of Netanyahu's dark
side has to do with his way of doing
politics Libby is a tough opponent who
has no qualms about attacking his rivals
through all possible means that is
precisely what he did in 1995 with Prime
Minister Itzhak Robin who he accused
among many other things of betraying
Jewish values the tension he generated
was so great that many detractors blame
him for fueling the hatred that ended
with Rabin's murder at the hands of an
extremist his critics say that Netanyahu
didn't pull the trigger but there is a
lack of political piety led to the
tragedy
so that Divya is the end of this video
about a politician who has a dark side
but also a very bright one as well he
has contributed to making Israel a much
more prosperous country but now is your
turn what do you think of Benjamin
Netanyahu do you think King Bibby has
been a good leader for Israel well leave
us your comments in the comment section
below as well as in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed this video if
you did please do hit that like button
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos every Monday and Thursday
also do not forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider Media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine and as always thank
you for watching
Israel is coming back to Africa and
Africa is coming back to Israel
[Music]